2021 has been a pretty great year for
esports lands are back tournaments are
hype and we've seen some insane plays
from crazy multi kills to insane
clutches 2021 has given us some
incredible moments so this week we
wanted to count down our absolute
favorites but before we get into that
our friends over at predator gaming are
helping us bring you another holiday
gift guide here's keith with what he
wants for the holiday season
you heard danny we've teamed up with our
friends over at predator gaming to bring
you guys a holiday gift guide this year
you're going to be getting to know each
and every one of our hosts a little bit
better and what we're looking to get our
hands on this holiday season and
hopefully we can give you guys some
ideas too let's get down to mine during
the pandemic i became well just a little
obsessed with custom mechanical
keyboards and you've got our friend
taeha who we covered in our offbeat show
to thank for that so naturally i gotta
put it in order for mode studio's new
mode 80 10 keyless custom mechanical
keyboard kit in black it's just too
clean i bought the dual shot 2 keycap
set a few months back and hopefully it
arrives before like 2025 and i can't
wait to pair the two together next up on
my list we've got the amy leon door new
balance 550 collab they're just the best
shoe of the year every time i record a
video the majority of the comments are
sneaker heads commenting on the shoes
behind me so you know i had to stay on
brand in my opinion new balance's
sneaker game had a massive coming out
party in 2020 and 2021 and this collab
is no joke i'd probably go with gray or
navy since they go with everything last
up we're going back to tech but with a
little bit more of a practical approach
the pandemic
seems to be chilling out a little bit
fingers crossed and that means we're
going to be back on the road for work
and i need a laptop that can handle
everything my job asked me
and my nightly gaming habits luckily our
friends over at predator gaming have
exactly what i need in the triton 500 se
laptop this thing's got an 11th gen 8
series core i7 processor and a 3060 all
jam-packed into a laptop body it also
has enough streamline cooling to not
completely roast your legs with all that
power and that's enough to make my
christmas list
easy you can check out the predator
triton series laptops at your local best
buy now let's get back to danny and the
top 10 plays of 2021
[Music]
thank you to keith for that and now it's
time to get into the top 10 plays of
2021
kicking off our list is safe and his big
brain double kill at the stockholm major
can you line up the double did he
actually do this there's one knife out
this was a great year for brazilian cs
there was an incredible amount of
representation at the major and things
are looking good for next year but
brazil is going to have to try pretty
hard to top safe's double kill against
astralis even if you get a kill here
you've got to be real careful makers
because leaning over from the other bomb
side i don't really blame safe for not
taking the shot right away because they
know it has to be lightning fast they
have to get a kill get the bomb plant
all in five or ten seconds so it's gonna
be can you line up the double did he
actually do this there's one knife's out
oh
save
now payne might have ended up losing
that round in fact they blew their lead
and ended up losing the series actually
but context doesn't matter when you pull
off a play that flashy
coming in at number nine is simple and
his record-breaking ace
simple to break the record no one has
found four aces
at a tournament like this and here it
comes a record breaker from simply takes
all five there are a ton of incredible
plays from simple's undefeated major win
that we could have put on this list but
we've gotta give respect to something
from a few months earlier the moment
simple broke the record for the highest
number of aces in a single event
fires off a warning shot and simple as
well does one better and they're just
walking in oh my goodness he just one
more for the ace alex record breaking
ace
he has got the opportunity and he's
going hunting for it appropriately it's
hunter that could give it to him
simple to break the record no one has
found four aces
at a tournament like this and here it
comes a record breaker from simply takes
all five that's right at iam colon 2021
the goat got four separate aces each one
was a beauty and that record-breaking
performance should remind you just how
dominant simple was this year
eighth place goes to heat quadruple no
scope ace from masters berlin he's
saying pretty he doesn't need to zoom in
get out of here get out
after a year of pro-balance we've seen
plenty of plays worthy of making this
list but this one is by far the best he
got four back-to-back marshall no scopes
to secure his ace against zeta division
let's see if there's anything left in
the tank what can they bring us here
already heat's gonna spot out most of
the plane also just takes off oh my
keeper's head the pull up as well
they're saying pretty he doesn't need to
zoom in
out of here
sure the marshall is a lot easier to
handle than the orp but that doesn't
make a play like this easy four no
scopes is insane
taking the seventh spot on our list is
danny's pentakill against hundred
thieves it's danny versus the hundred
thieves and daddy said he's gonna get
one danny could get two holy god he's so
damn good at this game in game four of
an lcs 2021 championship match evil
geniuses were on the ropes down 7k gold
with just three towers left standing it
seemed like 100 thieves were about to
close out the game hundred thieves
pushed to end the series with one last
team fight but danny held his ground
barrel damage the frontline might die
it's eg for serrando what damage doesn't
abu daga nearly kills him off contract's
gonna be low gonna be dropped one for
nothing push back now no one's left
alive they've gotta run they've gotta
run no danny steps up and danny shuts
down one mid laner is dento
danny is doing it
danny shuts down fbi the rookie of the
year puts his team on his back but he's
one versus two someday in abu dhabi can
only watch him knock down the wave as
they can't push the base without minions
and danny single-handedly keeps eg in
the upper bracket it's daddy versus the
world it's danny versus the hundred
thieves and danny said he's gonna get
one danny could get two holy god he's so
damn good at this game danny absolutely
dismantled the first three to get that
triple kill but for some reason someday
and abidargae decided to go back in and
feed themselves to danny boy for the
unofficial penta freak spits it i mean
said it best i can't
hear it
that was some of the best play i have
literally ever seen in league of legends
i agree but there are words to
it
coming in sixth place is this absurd
millisecond clutch from g2's virtue
against bds
at the last second wins it out
unbelievable with a few bullets to the
toes can do it can win you a whole map
ladies and gents we'll go into map
number two we know this happened in the
2020 eu finals but that event happened
in january 2021 so it's making the cuts
g2 were in overtime against bds and
virtue was stuck in a 1v4 brid was well
into planting the diffuser giving virtue
seconds to stop it but he was a floor
above them with no line of sight or so
we thought
here we go it's gonna all come down to
this 15 seconds i said they can't leave
it late there's the first one from pengu
starting off what happened in the last
round but two kills come flying through
virtue has got to do it all by himself
here if he wants to keep this one going
he finds one picking our friend shira
from above but he has got work to do can
you see the one go for the plan he sees
the feet he sprays
he just won that virtue downing him at
the last second wins it out unbelievable
with a few bullets to the toes can do it
can win you a whole lot ladies and gents
we'll go into map number two
cracking the top five is collapse and
his brutal skewers against og at t.i
pull them back usually again no tail
dies
yeah you want to give them a moonshot
you can go right with them all right
everyone was asking themselves if og had
it in them to win a third ti in a row
but team spirit answered that question
pretty quickly oh gee were down and were
relying on sumail to hard carry them but
collapse shut him down by skewering him
and no tail straight into the fountain
again he's sitting on the obs and
century after mail wait for toast again
they got two mail they don't have chrono
afterwards but they might not need it
mira continuing to control looking for
another round of this
rp gonna get off the market
collapse basically smurf ti with magnus
hitting skewer after skewer on his way
to lifting the aegis
coming in fourth place is viper and his
incredible clutch triple kill against
fpx
what how does viper do it how did he
manage the triple kill at the most
crucial point of the game in game four
of the lpl summer finals edg were down
fbx were looking to push the series to
game five and after they started a team
fight by killing two members of edg it
looked over things looked grim but viper
wasn't ready to give up just yet he
flashed forward into three members of
fpx and danced perfectly around them
while killing them all the jungler as
well don't be on the backlight incomes
flandre but the stopwatch has come on
through flights right with a huge narrow
ultimate maybe this is it but fbx still
firing out
ghosts
what how does viper do it how did he
manage the triple kill at the most
crucial point of the game any mistakes
would have surely been gg instead viper
denied fbx the infernal soul and opened
the door for an edg victory
coming in third place is refresh and his
insane galil 1v5 clutch against team
liquid doesn't swing he thinks it's a
fake refresh with all five and we're
going to overtime in map 3 of the esl
pro league season 14 quarterfinals it
looked like liquid had the series locked
up they were up 15-14 with all five
players up against only refresh all he
had was a galil but that was all he
needed can't find a thing still we have
fallen making it happen make it team
liquid be that semi-final he's three
fresh as good as he's been as much as
he's given us
this is a team liquid victory teed up
he's on for a third now i did as well
refresh how are you making this happen
grim the pit hero the guy who's dug deep
throughout this entire series to save
that a bomb site has now gonna come in
clutch at b
refresh on for the ace in a one-on-five
clutch
he's looking to keep his legacy in check
this never should have happened it
should have never been this close
grim his heart's racing his heart's
beating but refresh can't find him it's
your guessing game stick on the bomb
grim doesn't swing he thinks it's a fake
refresh with all five and we're going to
overtime depending on who you are that
play was either the nastiest most
inspiring clutch of all time or the most
soul-crushing moment of your entire life
sorry liquid fans
second place goes to rock man and the
most bm play of the year
welcome to msm everyone
what kind of read was that
most of the plays on this list have been
unbelievable innovative inspiring even
beautiful this play well it's all of
those things and more
so much more
wait wait a minute hold on yo welcome to
ultimate baby
are we playing
i'm at a loss of words this dude was
playing minecraft on him how do you even
come back from that
only one play could take the first place
on our list though kadian's historic
clutch against gambit to win pro league
the leader
calling well above his years clearing
corners
you're an animal
heroic have done it and i just can't
believe it 40 of their team only
together since february you know it i
know it we all know it p250 no armor
knife 2 hp it's the play of the year for
a reason oh yeah ah yeah oh oh my god
he's knifed him and he's gotten away
with the off i'm starting to get nervous
there's no way there's no way kaden you
can't win pro league like this you can't
win pro league like this
no way
exiles left 40 seconds and the bombs on
a take your time son you're about to
make the play of your career
the leader
calling well above his ears clearing
corners
you're an animal
heroic have done it and i just can't
believe it
they said he couldn't win pro league
like that but he did and we will never
forget
well there you go those were our top 10
plays of 2021. what do you think of
those were there any plays that didn't
make it on the list that you really
think should have been there either way
happy new year thanks for watching and
i'll see you all in 2022.
again the return kills coming in i have
no idea how this is happening range is
forcing his way in with kerrigan's help
the clutch my goodness kerrigan is there
time
oh my god very quick to go out there and
try and help sharks and now boom which
is in the corner they're not even gonna
check it he's gonna turn around you
didn't get your knife earlier oh no
no
the knife could have done it again